A few weeks ago,
you know it too,
and to add up they decided to oust the government.
"Our response was that we accepted the coup.
and that we were turning the page,
but that we would continue to promote policies
and courageous transformations from the start.
That was our intention.
"We have tried to do everything possible.
"
from the parliamentary group of sumar,
but it has proven impossible.
Therefore,
I announce that from now on
the deputies of we can
we move on to the mixed group
to ensure
our ability to make politics in the Atlantic
and to continue to promote
courageous measures
that the social majorities in this country need